I've explained to you already how Donald
Trump's trade war isn't winnable Trump
imposes tariffs on China so Chinese made
products get more expensive by the time
they reach the United States and that
means it's more expensive here and fewer
Americans can afford those products then
China counters and imposes retaliatory
tariffs on the United States that makes
our products more expensive in China
meaning fewer Chinese buy the products
meaning that the workers in the United
States who are manufacturing those
products also lose out so it's really
bad there's no off-ramp in sight there's
now an even worse problem going on which
John Healey writes about in a Chicago
Tribune article Donald Trump recently
said China is now paying us billions of
dollars in tariffs and hopefully we'll
be able to work something out he has no
idea how this all works because he's
flat wrong the tariffs on China are
attacks on American businesses and
consumers okay
when we put a tariff on China it ends up
with Americans paying more for Chinese
made Goods China's not paying for the
tariffs you're paying for the tariffs or
American businesses will end up
switching to more expensive American
materials when the Chinese products get
tariffs and then they simply pass on
that additional additional cost to the
end-user the purchaser of the product or
service so like one prime example right
now is the steel industry okay tariff on
Chinese steel well
suppliers add a surcharge to all
customers I wish they would label that
surcharge the surcharge for Trump's
tariff be totally transparent about it
fiber optics industry they're dealing
with more expensive connectors and power
plugs and all sorts of products so what
do they do they raise the price of the
finished product and it's the consumer
that ends up paying for it we just had
hurricane Florence in the southeast it's
time to rebuild now a very good article
in The New York Times points out that
the rebuilding is now going to cost more
because of Trump's tariffs the
construction materials that you will
need to rebuild from the hurricane
lumber Illume
steal more those now are tariffed
and builders are saying well it's going
to end up costing up to 30% more than
before because of the tariffs we pay
okay not China now to be clear the whole
point of tariffs is to make the foreign
product more expensive so that companies
will say oh well if the foreign products
more expensive I'm gonna buy domestic
instead and prop up the American
industry that's like the idea on paper
of these tariffs we just don't live in a
world where every country makes
everything as well as everybody else and
meets the demand that their country has
so we need international trade we should
do it responsibly we should do it
ethically we should organize trade in a
way that will be as fair as possible to
all parties and will really maximize
benefit and I agree we haven't always
done that I've never done that really
but when you look at something that we
need more of than we make like steel
if you tariffs Chinese steel you don't
shift all that demand to the US we still
need the Chinese steel we don't have
enough of the steel here in the United
States so all that ends up happening is
the costs get passed to the consumer or
the homeowner or whoever this is basic
economics we know Trump doesn't
understand basic economics we also know
he doesn't seem to really even
understand money as evidenced I guess
initially by that call at 3 a.m. to one
of his first national security advisors
Michael Flynn asking is a strong dollar
good or bad to which Michael Flynn of
course said I'm national security
advisor and it's 3:00 in the morning I
don't know what the hell you're talking
about
send me your thoughts about this as well
as about the Ted Cruz protest I'm on
Twitter at des Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and I hope
you'll follow us both one of today's
sponsors is Skillshare which is an
amazing online learning community that
offers thousands of high-quality classes
on almost any topic first 500 people who
click the link under this video will get
two entire months of totally free access
to every single class offered by
Skillshare they've got classes on
everything from design video editing
photography business technology cooking
meditation
even classes on personal productivity I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or even
something that will help you in your
everyday life classes are taught by real
people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of skill share but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up